chief medical correspondent dr john
lepux joins us with the next steps in
the race to develop a vaccine dr lupu
good morning so to make a vaccine
you've got to build it and then you've
got to distribute it i'd like to cover
both those points this morning on the
building side of things
the oxford study is promising what needs
to happen next
hey tony it's promising because it
elicited a strong immune response so it
should work and now the big question is
will it work and that means doing trials
in places throughout the world where
there's a lot of coronavirus to see
if it actually protects people from
getting the disease so they're going to
be trials
in south africa and brazil and the
united states in the united kingdom
and the million-dollar question is are
people who get the vaccine less likely
to come down with covet 19 that people
who don't
are there other promising candidates if
this one doesn't work out
you know there are there are several you
know there are there are more than a
hundred
candidates throughout the world there
are a small number that are being tested
and it's not going to just be one
vaccine that wins quote unquote because
you know there are billions of people in
the world we need several different ones
to work and then hopefully together we
can crowdsource
protecting everybody so once we have a
vaccine that we know
works how soon before we can manufacture
enough
doses to get them out to hundreds of
millions of people
they're doing something great with this
which is producing vaccine at risk
so in the past they would say let's wait
to see if it works if we've proven that
it works and then we'll start
manufacturing
now they're saying no let's just assume
that a small number are going to work
we're going to start manufacturing
hundreds of millions of doses in some
cases
soon like asap and if it turns out
that it doesn't work then that's lost
money but if it does work then bam
you're ahead of the game
well it doesn't work if you don't take
it well there's a poll that worried me
quite a bit it said
only about half of people would take the
vaccine
if it were shown to work what do you
make of that
you know i called david oshinski an
historian who wrote a pulitzer
prize-winning uh
book called polio an american story just
to get some historical perspective
and in the 50s people were terrified
about polio which caused infantile
paralysis about 15 000 cases a year in
the early 50s
and people rushed to get that vaccine
more than a million kids were part of
the trial in 1954.
he said that the difference between then
and now is people believed in science
now we have this hesitancy this um tony
thaucy
complained and was frustrated about an
anti-science bias and i think with all
the billions of dollars we're spending
on developing an effective and safe
vaccine
we have to put resources towards
communicating to people
here's why you should take it uh hear
hear the facts of the matter and really
go over with them uh
what's going on and why it's so
important for people to take the vaccine
that's a great point thanks for bringing
the facts of the matter to us dr lapook
thank you